[Music]
oh yes
yes
hey look the vikings knew what they were
doing we've talked about this kirk
cousins has the vikings in a bind
contractually they need to protect
themselves they've protected themselves
in round three with the guy who comes in
despite being taken
two rounds behind justin fields and dray
lance he's ahead of them yeah no
surprise because chris sims had
kellenbond ahead of both of those guys
in his pre-draft rankings nothing should
have changed since then there's kellen
at number 37. what do you think in sims
and i need to be sure that everyone
realizes that i had no role whatsoever
in the influence of the placement of
kellen monde at number 37. no this is
just you know two trains collided here i
love kellen mon you love the vikings and
they ended up on the same damn team i
don't know but either way yeah i mean
kellen mon it's the thing that jumped
out to me you could make the case the
argument that calvin mohn and mac jones
were the two best in the pocket passing
draftable college quarterbacks from this
past draft that's what i loved about him
i mean he's made for the nfl as far as
pocket passing is concerned you know
we've talked about his arm you see here
it's a really efficient release
technique-wise he never loses control of
the ball his whole career was in the
pocket nfl type drop back passing at
texas a m with not a star-studded
football team and he thrived thrived in
decision-making thrived in accuracy into
tight windows as good as anybody in the
draft and mike you know i'm big too
unlike the other things we talked about
a little yesterday in the pocket hey
unless you got like the best offensive
line in football the pocket's tight in
the nfl you feel like you're thrown from
a phone booth when you first get in
there you know you were on the middle of
a big prairie field in college football
and you get in the nfl and you're like
whoa everybody is really close to me and
they're big and being able to throw in
those tight those tight quarters like
that are paramount to being successful
and that's where i'm excited about mon
because you see it over and over at
texas a m
now the the little i remember about
my years as a baseball fan is that
the the stance can look a little funky
the wind up can look a little strange
it's not the wind up when you're getting
ready to hit but yeah i got you but it's
how it's how the bat comes through is
what matters right and for the best
hitters the bat always comes through the
same way it doesn't matter how it looked
ahead of time and i say that because
the the throwing motion itself looks
smooth but it looks a little funky he's
got the double chicken wing with the
elbows sticking out as he's setting up
i don't know how i feel about that yeah
no i you know again it's it it doesn't
look great but it's not technically bad
in fact it's like it's it's almost
technically perfect in a lot of ways
it's like school of coaching quarterback
type of stuff you do but what i want to
be is like hey you're you're good enough
now and you got the mechanic down
to what you're saying mike don't be so
robotic you know be loose let it go a
little bit right we saw aaron rodgers
come out of green out of cal holding the
ball up here and throwing the ball and
being all tight like that that's i think
the next thing for kel and mine you know
we talked about during the process get
better a little bit of the backyard
football aspect scrambling all those
things and be a little bit more loose
let your arm go he's got a really
special arm but the one thing he does do
mike is because he's so like that he's
very rarely out of position to throw the
ball properly um and he's aware of it i
think he is going to try to fix that he
said that to me in a pre-draft interview
but but but look at look at how the ball
is protected yeah that position yes he
gets hit like that it's far less likely
no doubt squirt out and again when it's
time to throw it it's it is a quick
release it's a deceptively quick release
the ball is out so it doesn't matter
whether it's front and center or up
above one shoulder it just looks a
little funky it does it looks it looks
different but maybe he's doing it right
yeah no it is it's a little bit like you
know quarterback school 101 if i was
gonna have a young kid you know that's
the type of thing you do okay two hands
on the ball let's protect the football
and now that's how you learn to throw
with your body and do those type of
things and not make it all arm type
throws i think he'll learn this because
he's got talent and he'll realize that
you know he's got to relax a little
maybe throw balls sidearm and do those
type of things but the talent is real
you know i keep coming back to like i
think this is going to be the dak
prescott of this draft everyone made up
all these reasons of why he's not a
first rounder and then he's gonna get in
an nfl game and everyone's gonna go damn
it looks like a first rounder to me just
like what happened with dak prescott
it's like the first game you were like
oh it kind of looks the part i think
dallas is gonna be okay with tony romo
so i love the talent
i like the way he handles himself i
think he really knows how to play the
position mike that's the other thing i
like too one of the things that jumped
out to me is he wasn't in a
really great creative offense or didn't
have first round receivers around them
and they had some moments where they
were ugly on offense during the year but
the thing i liked about it is in those
moments he wasn't like i'm frustrated my
stats aren't good i'm gonna just start
throwing lasers and throwing the ball
into tight windows and we'll see what
happens
he continued to play the game the right
way and never lost any games for his
teams that way in those tough moments
that's really showed me a lot of
maturity for a young quarterback at
texas a m and he fits that offense there
in minnesota mike that's what i'm really
excited about too
well you know i've said it before he can
do the things that kirk cousins can't do
which is by time if the play that's
called goes to hell yeah the question is
can he do the things that cousins does
when the play that's called doesn't go
to hell because that's where cousins is
underappreciated if everything goes the
way it's supposed to
he'll deliver the football to an open
receiver and you'll score points and
you'll win games but but
you always have 11 guys who are trying
to stop you from doing
the thing that you want to do and you
got to have guys who can pivot when the
defense wins the battle yeah you need a
guy who can still win the war yeah that
that's where his potential can improve
and it's where he already has more
talent than kirk cousins that way i mean
kellen man's got the type of speed to
you know get outside on a bootleg oh
nobody's open and go run for 50 yards up
the sideline i mean that's he does have
that and then where he does also has and
these guys on that team are going to see
just like we go back to that throw with
his personal workout right hey kirk
cousins really good hey kevin mann hey
he knows how to read a defense and
deliver on the place where the offense
works and all that too but they're going
to see also go wait nobody was open and
did you see that freaking throw he made
holy cow nobody was open and he did that
that's the other aspect he's going to
bring you know kirk cousins has an
underrated arm but it's not is like it
it's not like this kid this kid's got a
special arm like we saw in that pro day
where he can go one way floating in the
air and throw a ball 60 yards the other
direction with his feet off the ground
and also throw it 60 feet 60 yards up in
the air as well he's got a cannon for an
arm and that's where it can be exciting
for your vikings offense with thielen
and jefferson a few years down the road
when that question came up last week
about the all-time great deep threats in
nfl history and the vikings posted the
10-minute clip of all of the randy moss
40-plus yard touchdowns there's a chunk
in the middle where there's a guy who
wears number 11 who was firing rockets
20 years ago for the vikings and dante
culpepper and and you know that between
the arm and the mobility
it's something the vikings haven't had
since culpepper in the quarterback
position they haven't had both combined
in one they've had some of each but they
haven't had it combined the way they
have a combined and kalamon so we'll see
how it goes now the next one you could
argue as surprising if not more
surprising than mond at 37 marcus
mariota the second overall pick back in
2015 comes in at 36. he took a huge pay
cut to stay with the raiders he played
well last year during a game where derek
carr exited and came back pretty damn
quickly when marcus mariota played well
why do you have him as high as you do
well he missed just missed out on the
top 40 last year i wasn't really sure
what to think of him and of course he
had been benched by ryan you know for
ryan tannehill and tennessee it was a
little underwhelming at the end with the
titans i still have some of my concerns
i am going off a lot of that one game of
what we saw last year but i thought it
was damn good and he still has i think
the thing that i came back to tubed and
i like turned on film of him last week
to write some notes on things that jump
out to me about guys he still has a
great presence on the field and yes he
can get better at being a better
consistent thrower even in that one game
he played good but through like an
interception towards the end in the
fourth quarter where you just go wait
you can't miss that throw and be an nfl
starting quarterback but either way size
pretty good arm
and uh you know unflappable as far as
the attitude or being affected by you
know the game or anything like that and
the other thing i think that just you
know jumped out to me from that game i
mean the running is real it's real he
puts pressure on a defense from that
aspect of yeah where maybe we wish he
threw the ball a little bit better and
put a pressure on the defense that way
but the fact that he can look at one and
two and tuck it and run down the
sideline for a 40-yard gain puts a lot
of pressure on a defense too so yeah i i
i like what i saw from marcus mariota in
that one game and i guess i'm also given
a little bump because he's around a guy
like john gruden and i know he's learned
and and polished his game a little bit
under him a little bit
it'll be interesting to see what happens
after this season the contract expires
carr's still the guy in las vegas it's
not like they're going to take mario
over carr right but where does mariota
go does he get a chance to become a
starter again yeah with someone else but
uh you have a lot of faith in and we'll
see if the rest of the league does
when he becomes a free agent after the
2021 season ends yeah i i think so you
know mike i mean i think it's gonna be
maybe the possibility of almost like
what we saw this year i would think new
england watched that game and went damn
okay wait he's done some good things he
knows how to play the team game we saw
them do that in tennessee you know they
probably looked at and go wait we could
fix some of the passing issues and do
all that but we heard those rumors early
on in the off season you know because i
think that's where marcus mariota if he
wants to get back into court starting
quarterback bill
it's probably going to be a scenario
like that hey we're going to take you
give you a one-year flyer type of thing
let's see what happens and can he
capitalize and show improvements in
areas he needs to show improvement so
we'll see where that is but again i
think there's a lot of things alike and
he's one of those borderline starting
quarterback type talents
a la really awesome backup to have
coming off the bench
and you know we talk about this from
time to time as the draft approaches how
much a guy's first nfl destination
impacts his career
do you find yourself wondering whether
or not things would have gone
differently from marcus mariota if he
hadn't been taken by the titans at the
time the titans had what they had the
help around and the coaching around him
i i yeah this gets back this gets back
to my get rid of the draft and let these
guys pick their their nfl spot because
you are
to a certain extent a potential victim
of where you end up yeah you are and you
know yeah like you said when he was
there it wasn't great wide receiver play
it still was about you know running the
football and doing those type of things
there
so i i always think of things like that
yes
you know and of course wasn't with
you know any offenses offensive geniuses
early on in his career some good you
know minds we know that and everything
like that but yeah i certainly think his
career could have gone differently if he
went with a top flight oc or something
like that but regardless of the
situation
you know the one thing he had in
tennessee that was an issue he did some
good things we know that turnovers were
an issue not just like interceptions
remember fumbles were an issue there too
so it was fumbles
and turnovers and i think ultimately
a little bit of a lack of aggressive
mindset as a dropback passer and just a
little too much inconsistencies that has
dropped him to back up quarterback bill
that's really all it is and uh we'll see
that game this year he was definitely a
little bit more aggressive and i thought
he threw the ball as good as i've seen
him throw it for the most part other
than that one interception
you know i got to give you credit for
this because when the titans traded for
ryan tannehill two years ago i kind of
felt it but you were adamant they're
going to bench him
they're going to bench mariota for
tannehill and they did and that was that
from thank you for giving me credit
i'll do it once a year